I got [ __ ] there's too much [ __ ]
on tv man I drove by the other day on
[ __ ] Sunset Boulevard and it says
Shark Week
with your Master of Ceremonies The Rock
you know
like what how that's I and I said this
before on this podcast I don't
understand
how much you need to work
like
take like and I don't like I know
nothing about the rock I'm sure he's a
[ __ ] nice person and a great family
man but it's like
you've got a billion dollars
what you doing being the master
ceremonies on the Discovery Channel
what you doing
hey you got a billion dollars you have
billions and billions of dollars
in your bank account you don't use it
you don't use billions of dollars
so The Rock
what you doing
hey Rock what are you doing being the
Master of Ceremonies of Shark Week
there are a few guys who don't have to
worry about [ __ ] diluting their brand
though like him Kevin Hart Kevin Hart
he's got like shows it's like
he's like I got pants now I'm selling
pants and you're like oh okay is that
even successful he's like I'm gonna be
the first billion dollar comedian now
you want to buy pants
and you're like I I okay I'll buy these
[ __ ] pants that he's selling I guess
you know
how much could they be paying the Rock
for Shark Week Master he's probably at
home he's probably at this point got his
own studio in his house with a green
screen and he's like oh Hammerheads oh
boy Hammerheads are [ __ ] crazy check
this this footage out of this near-death
experience you don't want to get too
close to Hammerheads or tiger sharks
just drinking his [ __ ]
tramana or whatever
just is his ozoa or whatever the [ __ ] is
uh
uh [ __ ] power drink is oh God huh
do you you see tiger sharks just drunk
as [ __ ] with his shirt off doing dips
drinking his Ozawa or whatever the [ __ ]
it is
zoa dude I don't know anything about the
drink but I guarantee he's like from the
feeling of being a Hawaiian
I guarantee like in the commercial or
the ad he's just always like this is the
essence of when you're feeling Hawaiian
and you drink it and now it tastes like
that true essence of a friendship in
Hawaii or whatever the [ __ ] ah zoa
from the essence of the family this is
from tried and true family when you're
coming up in Hawaii
you know the rock is from [ __ ]
Detroit or some [ __ ]
um
I just don't understand it like Kevin
Hart's doing game shows and [ __ ]
for what
10 million dollars
then they have like nine kids never hate
on the [ __ ] man Kevin Hart is I know
you know I know him he's a great guy I'm
just this is jokes
don't know the rock I'm sure he's a
great guy just jokes I actually because
I you know what I appreciate those guys
I'm making fun but I do appreciate those
guys but it's but still how hard you
need to work dude that's so crazy to me
dude you know what I you know what I'm
doing you know what I do you know I'm
doing if I ever make a hundred million
you know what I'm doing if I ever make a
[ __ ] hundred million dollars
chilling dude for [ __ ]
dude you won't you won't see me dude
you won't
[ __ ] see me man
if I ever make a hundred million dollars
oh dude
I'm walking around in bird box from now
on dude hey if I make a hundred million
dollars all of a sudden
everyone's Daredevil dude you won't
see me
I swear to God if the second I make that
bother me I say 50 dude if I make
50 million dollars dude all of a sudden
oh playing hide and hiding for the rest
of our lives where'd Chris D'Elia go oh
I don't know check out bird box
dude you won't this is oh bro that's it
and the only song I'm ever listening to
ever again is [ __ ]
hey hey
goodbye
hey
goodbye that's it dude just [ __ ]
watching The Last Samurai on repeat for
the rest of my life I don't give a [ __ ]
man I am done dude
I'm in a boat somewhere I sort of got
naked as [ __ ] only wearing a shirt
that's it just wearing a shirt just
dangling around bleep it to keep it age
restricted I should have said schlong or
hot dog whatever the [ __ ] man dude just
only a shirt only a Blazer actually
that's it
so it's still open
a [ __ ] or an oversized shirt just
[ __ ] you know hot dog dangling so
it's like like a bell like like a bell
you know like the shirts Puffs out and
then like a bell
whatever dude
I swear to God man I'm done okay so
subscribe to my patreon but also don't
too much because I'm done
when your boy makes 50 milli
um
I Love Lil Wayne dude
when he does that in the beginning of
Lollipop
almost passed out when I did that I ran
out of breath
um if you like the channel subscribe man
it really helps man you know what I mean
it's all good
[Music]
I'm crazy you're crazy
[Music]